(upbeat music)
- Yo.
(intense music)
- What are you wearing?
- They're just shorts.
- You can't just be
rocking shorts like that.
- They're just my legs.
- Why do you look like The
Rock from the waist down?
Doesn't our office have
some sort of dress code?
You just decide to walk up
here and act like it's no big
deal that you have the
greatest calves of all time?
Do you have soccer tryouts after work?
Why are you dressed like a teacher
who I would run into at a Blockbuster?
Why are you dressed like you're
about to give me swim lessons?
- It's hot out.
- Is every day leg day for you?
Why do your calves look
like they could beat me up?
I'll bet your mom had to get a C-section
because of those bad boys.
If the apocalypse happened right now,
I'd eat you immediately.
Have you never used an escalator?
Have you ever ridden in a car?
Are you some sort of experiment
between a boy and a horse?
You could have gotten some
kind of scholarship for those.
Those calves are the size
of a calf, as in baby cow.
Lebron James would definitely go back home
to play for those calves.
Do you normally wear baggy
pants and because of your calves
they look like skinny jeans?
You look like you could hike
a mountain in six seconds.
Have you ever sat down?
Tell me why I wanna take a can of Pam
and just spray your calves right now.
I cannot take you seriously
when you're wearing those Daisy Dukes.
How?
Look at that, oh my goodness.
Do I have to send your
calves a Christmas card now?
- Hey, eyes up here.
- When you run, do your calves chafe?
I'm sure every girlfriend you've ever had
has motorboated those puppies.
Did you calves accidentally
sink the Titanic?
Why do you look like you
live on the 67th floor
of a hotel with a broken elevator?
- Are you done?
- Yeah, I'm done.
Sorry, I was just,
maybe you should warn me
next time you wear shorts to the office.
(gentle music)
Gosh.
(upbeat music)